une visite sur le thème de la mobilité
et de la restauration scolaire
l'objet du déplacement à trappes de
julien bayou cette commune
un véritable laboratoire pour la
politique écologiste et sociale voulue
par la liste l'écologie évidemment
retient évidemment l'enjeu de
démocratiser l'écologie et ferb de
trappes et de la région ile de france
le phare de la transition écologique
notamment l'écologie populaire qui est
parce que les quartiers populaires les
classes populaires les classes moyennes
sont les premières bénéficiaires
bénéficiaires de l'action écologique
on le voit avec la cantine scolaire ça
permet à chaque enfant d'avoir un vrai
repas équilibrés cette liste rassemble
plusieurs mouvements politiques de
gauche
parmi eux génération point s créé par
benoît hamon candidat socialiste à
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
l'ancien député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines a quitté le
ps après ce recul avec la politique il
est candidat dans la liste de julien
bayou là on a un rassemblement vraiment
bilingue qui est capable de parler
d'écologie transition écologique mais
aussi de penser les impacts en termes de
justice sociale qui ne fait pas en étant
en considérant que le développement
économique c'est pas une bonne chose au
contraire en essayant de penser la
cohérence de ces choix là dans les
yvelines la candidature l'écologie
évidemment est porté par ghislaine ce
n'est conseil régional depuis 2010 elle
se lance dans sa troisième campagne en
ile de france
il va y avoir la la la révision du
schéma directeur de la région
ile-de-france un schéma d'aménagement
ça peut se faire qu'en concertation et
avec les maires et avec la population
parce que pour assumer et pour
réellement porter cette transition
écologique il faut que tous les acteurs
soient soient soient partants les
franciliens sont appelés aux urnes le
dimanche 13 juin 2021 pour élire les 209
futurs conseillers régionaux d'île de
france